hey wisecracks
Jared again while there are plenty of
recent films that have disappointed us
today we decided to go back in time to
summer 2003 a time when 14-year old me
was waiting in line 6 hours early to
catch a glimpse at what would end up
being one of the biggest disappointments
of my fanboy life welcome to this
wisecrack edition on The Matrix Reloaded
what went wrong and in case you've been
living under a rock spoilers ahead part
of the reason why the original matrix
worked so well was that a couple deep
philosophical themes with a tight
structure influenced heavily by Joseph
Campbell's idea of the monomyth in the
hero with a thousand faces
Campbell explains that a hero's journey
can be broken down into three phases
separation from the world a penetration
to some source of power and a life
enhancing return this is a classic
structure one that's been used time and
time again
slava Dziedzic I mean Dan Harmon writer
of wisecrack favorite Rick and Morty
says that this model is hardwired into
our nervous system and trust that in a
vacuum or raised by wolves our stories
would follow this pattern but where does
the story go once this cycle is complete
once the protagonist has become in
Campbell's words master of two worlds in
a Neos case freakin Superman this is the
problem the Wachowski spaced in writing
The Matrix Reloaded and it's a pretty
difficult problem once your characters
become all-powerful how do you craft a
meaningful story arc with believable
internal and external conflict to their
credit the Wachowski solution is pretty
smart at least in theory well they can't
change the fact that neo is essentially
invincible they can ask but what if his
godlike powers are as someone in a much
better sequel once said that's all part
of the plan and this forms the central
plot of the Matrix Reloaded over the
course of the film neo and the audience
slowly realized that the prophecy is
just another form of control the one
never meant to end anything it was all
another system with control all of Neos
powers aren't evidence of him
transcending the system his ability to
do these things are just another part of
the system in other words neo isn't
breaking free from the matrix in any
meaningful way but rather playing a
predetermined role in a larger system
which brings us to the central problem
of the film action now when we say
action we don't mean over-the-top fight
sequences which there are plenty of
instead what we're talking about here is
dramatic action or any choice that a
character makes to advance their goal in
the overall plot of the film these don't
have to be big weighty choices they can
be as small as Luke deciding to follow
r2d2 on its mission to find obi-wan and
when it comes down to it there just
isn't much dramatic action in the Matrix
Reloaded add in the fact that all of
Neos choices are just an illusion
created by a larger system of control
and you start to realize that there's
actually no dramatic action here zero
zip none instead were bogged down by
lengthy philosophically confused
monologues about determinism determinism
loosely believes that through cause and
effect every moment in the future is
dictated by a moment in the past think
of it like watching dominoes fall if you
know which domino falls first you can be
certain which one falls next and on and
on and on until the end the Matrix
Reloaded takes this philosophy and runs
with it the opening scene is actually
from the film's closing moments
hammering home that the events of the
past have already cemented the film's
ending in the scene neo dreams of
Trinity kicking ass with a bike helmet
before being shot factor in that The
Matrix has restarted six times already
and you begin to realize that the film's
ending isn't just predetermined but that
the whole world has been literally stuck
in a loop the punch clock in the guards
office strikes midnight showing the
literal completion of a circle and a
seamless transition from one day's end
to another's beginning cinema and the
key-maker
while explaining his plan to infiltrate
the tower says that they have exactly
seconds for neo to reach the architect a
conspicuously exact amount of time which
happens to be the first three digits of
pi
sidenote pi also shows up in other
places too like being spray-painted on
the wall outside the Oracles apartment
these images are constant reminders that
neo isn't blazing a new path but rather
retreading a circle for the sixth time
neo awakes from this dream worried as
only Keanu Reeves can possibly emote
importantly there are no choices made in
this opening except for neo choosing to
admit I wish I knew what I'm supposed to
do where is our first point of dramatic
action you asked the first moment when a
character makes a decision to advance
his or her goals and the plot well
that's a long way off
in fact it's another 39 minutes off
almost the whole first hour of the film
involves Morpheus and crew playing
politics while they seek the Oracle
this gives us such memorable moments as
pilgrims asking neo to bless their
objects like Jesus future tribal rave
scene 2.0 and a prolonged conversation
between neo and counts for Hamid that
makes sure the audience knows that the
movie is going to question Neos agency
doesn't make one wonder just what is
control so when does the dramatic action
actually start here it's not until neo
finally locates the Oracle 44 minutes
into the movie that the protagonist is
given their quest and starts their
journey
compare this to Star Wars where Luke
receives Leia's message at about the 20
minute mark and when this moment finally
comes in typical Matrix Reloaded style
the film decides to beat the living crap
out of us with its weighty deterministic
philosophy first because you didn't come
here to make the choice you've already
made it
neo wonders what he should do but the
Oracle reminds neo and the viewers that
it doesn't matter
Neos already made his choice are you
saying I have to choose whether Trinity
lives or dies no we've already made the
choice now you have to understand it
that's right in case we were hoping that
neo would make a choice here we were
wrong so to recap the inciting incident
is just a bunch of philosophical
exposition that reminds us that neo has
no agency at all fun real fun but what
about Neos quest you can say
if you reach the source but to do that
you will need the key-maker
the keema is being held prisoner by a
very dangerous program one of the oldest
Sufis it's called the Merovingian yup
Neos journey is literally a glorified
fetch quest
you know those obnoxious gathering
quests that have been ruining RPGs for
thirty years now but at least in those
quests we know why we're starting them
all Neos left with is vague instructions
but don't worry
the Wachowski sensing their audience
might be getting annoyed now decide to
add in an action scene with agent smith
and surprise surprise before attacking
neo smith delivers a monologue on you
guessed it determinism we're not here
because we're free we're here because we
are not free there's no escaping reason
no denying purpose because as we both
know without purpose we would not exist
yup while neo might think he's free
Smith is trying to tell him that he's
only found by a larger system of cause
and effect just like counselor Hammond
and the Oracle teased earlier instead of
having this deterministic theme grow
organically through Neos actions the
Matrix Reloaded decides to just tell us
straight up over and over again then we
have another action sequence that
demonstrates Neos godlike power a scene
that doesn't advance the plot at all
adding insult to injury this fight scene
goes on for well over six minutes and
looks like it was directly ripped from a
dynasty Warriors game an hour into the
film and finally the plot begins to move
neo and the crew meet with the
Merovingian to haggle over the key-maker
the Merovingian is a reference to the
Merovingian order which supposedly
guarded a book detailing the location of
the holy grail keeping with the film's
christian symbolism the key maker is the
book here while the source is the Grail
but this wouldn't be the Matrix Reloaded
without another unnecessary speech on
determinism the only truth
action-reaction cause-and-effect
everything begins with choice no wrong
choice is an illusion to prove his point
in what might go down as the most
ridiculous scene in an already
ridiculous movie our French friend here
decides to send a girl a piece of cake
designed to make her orgasm yeah that
just happened this is now the fourth
ramble sesh teasing to neo that he's
just a puppet on strings but the
Merovingian decides to withhold the
key-maker so keymakr is mine and i see
no reason why I should give him
luckily for neo and company and
unluckily for the audience the group
doesn't have to think of a clever
solution to retrieve the key maker which
is you know what protagonists usually do
when faced with an obstacle
instead the Merovingians lady friend
Persephone offers them up in exchange
for a kiss with neo I'll give you what
you want but you have to give me
something what and if you think that's
male fantasy for you know that the
script actually described her as sex and
death squeezed into a woman's business
suit made of latex yeah
then begins the movie's largest action
sequence taking up 22 minutes or the
length of an entire television show and
this scene doesn't make a whole lot of
sense if you think about it if neo is
just playing into the hands of the
architect like all his other past
incarnations why is it necessary that
the agents chase the key-maker
the Exile is goodbye my target after all
if they delete him the neo can't reach
the source and reintegrate his code
which means that the matrix is super
screwed because Agent Smith is going
rogue and there's nothing to stop him so
both of the film's biggest action
set-pieces served no purpose in the
narrative factor and how much time has
been wasted talking about determinism
and you realize this film can't have
spent more than 20 minutes advancing the
plot but there's not much time to think
about this because the film moves into
its third plot point well past the 90
minute mark the journey to the source
this is supposed to be the climax of the
film but it really doesn't feel like it
for starters we already know what
happens when the group infiltrates the
Tower
despite neo telling Trinity to staff
we know that she'll go in anyway and get
herself shot as a result meanwhile once
neo reaches the source he doesn't come
up against some insurmountable foe who
forces him to become one with himself
and the universe partially because this
already happened in the first film nope
we're given typical Matrix Reloaded fair
again instead of fulfilling dramatic
action we get more exposition a big ol
information dump your life is the sum of
a remainder of an unbalanced equation
inherent to the programming of the
matrix the architect explains the role
of the prophecy and how neo must
eventually surrender his code to the
matrix mainframe like his five
predecessors have done before him thus
saving Zion from complete destruction if
there's any hope for neo making a choice
here rest assured the film is hell-bent
on taking away his agency your five
predecessors were by design based on a
similar predication a contingent
affirmation that was meant to create a
profound attachment to the rest of your
species facilitating the function of the
one while the others experienced this in
a very general way your experience is
far more specific visa vie love the
architect even says that neo was
specifically designed to feel loved more
than his predecessors and just to make
sure the film really hammers the point
home when neo is presented with the
choice of either saving Zion or going to
rescue Trinity the architect reminds us
we already know what you are going to do
don't we
after five monologues on determinism and
caused an effect I think yes yes yes we
do neo flies off to save Trinity
removing a bullet from her abdomen
surprising no 1 after 2 hours and 18
minutes the audience is left wondering
what the hell they just watched
sure a lot more happened on screen than
in the original there were more flight
scenes more characters more plot twists
so why does it feel like nothing
actually happened the answer here lies
in our own natural sense of dramatic
action there are only four main plot
points here neo finds the Oracle neo
finds the key-maker neo reaches the
source and neo saves Trinity that's it
these moments are then diluted by
unnecessary sermons on determinism
sermons which if you can actually follow
them just remind you that neo has no
agency if
Neos choices are predetermined how is
anybody supposed to root for him let
alone care what happens it seems like
the entire point of this two-hour 18
minute movie is to get the audience to
ask themselves can do actually make
choices can he break free from the
system of control the very same one we
thought he already broke free from in
the first movie instead of answering
this the Matrix Reloaded tells us to
watch the two-hour long Matrix
Revolutions to find out great just great
thanks for watching wise crack if you're
like us you're always searching for ways
to work smarter not harder well we just
discovered an awesome youtuber named
Thomas Frank aka college info geek and
his channel is loaded with tips and
advice for being more productive whether
at school or in your day to day life you
might want to check out his video on how
to cut down your study time using what's
called the Fineman technique or for
those of you who aren't in school
anymore watch his episodes on bettering
your sleep schedule waking up motivated
and ending your procrastination check
out thomas frank using the link in the
description and be sure to subscribe to
his channel while you're over there and
if you like all the stuff we make and
want to help us do more maybe consider
becoming a patron we now have a growing
library of patron only content including
a new podcast I recorded yesterday on
Wonder Woman we're working on more
patreon exclusives each month like early
access to upcoming videos quick takes
and more so check out our patreon page
by clicking here and don't forget to
check out college info geek with these
links here until next time wisecrack e's